what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
plena you buy liva marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
and she's got a black t-shirt on in
dress code don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block fi you can earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account i'm
an investor i say on the board
and i am a very happy user of
block by go check them out you can earn
up to eight point six percent
apy and an interest bearing account go
to blockfy.com
again blockby.com pomp and let's
do it i'm gonna get paid what's up
what's up
lady oh so today wait can i tell them
really fast
sure okay so so this morning i was over
here
and he was in there doing a podcast and
uh
i just hear the podcast person go okay
who's your celebrity crush
and i was like and he goes
oh my celebrity crush paulina my wife
and i was like
i'm a celebrity were you more shocked
are you more shocked that i said that
you were a celebrity or because i said
that
you were my answer to the question both
both okay all right what's going on with
the topics now we got relationship
advice over it's not advice okay another
860
000 americans filed for unemployment
benefits last week
god it's not going down like a broken
record that would be the highest
unemployment week in history it took out
2020 although it is another week-on-week
decline for jobless claims
as the jobs recovery drags on
i wouldn't call it a recovery being
called a recovery if more people lost
their jobs last week
than any other week in history outside
of this year yeah
that's how bad it still is this is
terrible yesterday we went to uh no
all right uh when when we saw that old
man applying for a job as a waiter
it just broke my heart okay
we don't know that he was doing that
because i literally saw him doing that
okay airline ceos meet with white house
in last minute plea for more coronavirus
eight
their airline ceos and unions are
seeking another 25 billion in federal
aid to preserve jobs through march
wait didn't we say that in october was
everything when
everything would go down burn it down
burn it down get these people
out of their jobs why are they running
these businesses
well how are you gonna preserve jobs
that's not the government's job
is to preserve jobs that is not the
government's job okay but
the free market is not being allowed to
operate
the the three ceos who run these
businesses are bad at their job
including american yeah they're bad at
their jobs now
look again it's not because
they're bad they're put in a position
where you have to put them through
bankruptcy
because they're bankrupt companies if
they don't have the aid
and you have to allow the equity holders
to get wiped
and get it recapitalized in the hands of
new owners and be off to the races again
what you are doing by giving them aid is
you are
putting more firepower behind a monopoly
okay okay
when is the last american era last
airline based in america that got
created and has
broken into the top 10. i think it's
hard to create an airline
because it's a bunch of
dudes with suits and ties on to act like
a cartel he doesn't like the suits
it's just let them fail they're failing
businesses that's what we're seeing
they're literally running to the
government and they're saying we can't
get equity or debt on the terms that
you're willing to give it to us because
you're the sucker in the room government
so hey government give us money remember
last time we did this
we gave them billions of dollars and
two-thirds of it
they don't pay back and we got no equity
they received 25 billion in march
they won another and two-thirds of it
was for free
they took taxpayer money and they gave
it to the airlines for free
and the airlines got 25 billion and
still don't know how to
survive they won another 25. but here's
my question
burn it down but here's my question
letting them fail
wouldn't it be bad overall for society
how are you going to travel
the planes don't disappear they go into
bankruptcy
the planes are still there the
businesses still run
it's just that they get equity wiped and
then what they do is they recapitalize
the business somebody buys it out of
bankruptcy
and then they're off to the races and
usually better management will come in
what's happening is you have family
business it's like saying hey
these five people all want to play on
the basketball team they all
suck and rather than let's go find other
people who may be better so that we can
make our team better
instead these five are saying nope you
gotta pick one of us
you gotta pick one of us should i start
an airline
you can't because there's a cartel this
is this is absurd if they give this
25 billion dollars to them again stay
off the internet they're meeting with
the white house so we'll see yeah
they're literally again just like i said
when they did this in march
they're running to the dumb money in the
room which is they're running to the
government and asking for money on terms
that no investor in the equity or debt
market would give them
there's no investor in the world that
gives you billions of dollars and says i
just keep it
you don't have to pay me back i don't
get i get no equity in your business
but u.s government did it don't be the
sucker in the room
yeah it's just crazy ready yes
richard branson spak richard branson has
joined the crush of high-profile
investors seeking to raise money for
blank check
companies pitching a 400 million dollar
spec
that would hump for deals to expand
virgin groups brand in the us
now we forget that richard branson has
already done a spec or he's been part of
a
jamal acquired right chamoth
palapatiya yes and adam payne we gotta
stop forgetting about adam bain
adam bain is he part of it yeah he's
jamal's partner
shout out so they they both started this
spec
and acquired virgin galactic back in
2019 or 18.
and so yeah oh in 19 yeah so
now branson wants to create a spec
to acquire companies yeah
400 million look if you have an airline
company you might acquire it
i like this for him to do
if he finds the right business because
it's all about he has the name brand
people oh richard branson's gonna do
something richard branson does big
things i want to be a part of it he's
gonna be able to raise the money 400
million is not that much for these two
remember bill ackman raised four billion
dollars
yeah so i think it's a good idea we'll
see what type of business he wants to
buy
i interviewed branson once did he hit on
you
i hate you he knows the story please
don't okay he hit on her
and i was he didn't he's just an old man
and
it regardless we're not gonna get into
this
okay richard we'll talk anthony got a
little
bone to pick beef okay um
i like him you know tonal
yeah tonal is a fitness startup
uh it raised an additional 110 million
dollars after seeing surging demand for
its at home
strength training machines during the
pandemic i think this is going to be a
whole trend what is the uh valuation
do we know it remains under a rebellion
oh
so they sold more than ten people why
are you getting out of i keep trying to
include you
okay come on so what's going on here so
basically a bunch of really high-profile
people have invested in this including
amazon's alexa fund that's interesting
golden state warriors steph curry
professional golfer michelle
wait wait me paul george
bobby wagner of the seahawks
so a bunch of celebrities yeah i mean
look there's a bunch of people who are
all
raising lots and lots of money right now
uh we'll see if they win well
tonal then there's uh peloton then
there's what else there's a bunch of
studio
studio i'm an investor shout out studio
you shout them out studio okay okay
studio's gonna win facebook
shared early demos of something called
infinite office
which is a new set of features that will
bring solo productivity to
oculus quest so basically you'll be able
to put this on
and think that you're in your office
virtual
because that's what we need well users
will receive live feeds from the onboard
camera so that they
can integrate the vr world with their
own home the company announced this
partnership
and it allows certain keyboards to be
recognized tracked and rendered inside
the headset so users can easily input
text while working inside the quest
facebook says that more features will be
rolling out over the coming months and
that early releases would focus on
personal productivity
rather than group collaboration this is
actually very smart wait why
because focusing on like the the uh one
player
yeah right uh like uh player
one experience one player experience
versus
multiplayer experience is much easier to
just build for one person so now i've
got all my screens
i can type in virtual reality right
and now i can get a bunch more work done
be more productive
by immersing myself in a virtual
environment rather than having to be
held by the constraints of my physical
environment around me
okay i just think that offices are gonna
try to use this of like hey
come into the office virtually don't you
think that's gonna happen
but that's not what it's about it's
about having a virtual experience here
you're not like teleporting
no i know but like if me and all my
co-workers uh were to go into the office
virtually and we can interact with that
would be group collaboration
oh okay solo i see okay
solo means one
just saying you be careful before your
celebrity crush
makes me so low that would have been
good
see that joke see how the jokes just
roll go on
let's go b-i-g do you guys remember when
we talked about notorious big's crown
it was a for auction greatest rapper
ever
guess how much it sold for six hundred
thousand almost six hundred thousand
dollars at auction oh really
yeah sotheby's hip-hop auction also
raises
a hundred twenty six thousand dollars
for a 12-inch copy of
ramazeel's track beat bop okay which was
artwork whatever the plastic crown
costing six dollars worn by notorious
big has sold for
594 thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars
wow it cost six dollars originally hey
inflation man i'm kidding
if you makes that was pretty good
actually uh
let's see the crown was used by
photographer baron claiborne in
portraits made three days before the
rapper's murder and a drive-by shooting
and it's signed by the notorious b.i.g
it features one point broken off some
general light wear and abrasions
according to the listing
the sale price was double the 200 to 300
000
estimate who do you think bought it a
rich person
yeah but like who i don't know wait hold
on what would they say
a cachet go down a little bit more a
cachet of 22 love letters sent by tupac
shakur his high school sweetheart kathy
loy
sold for 75 000. they showed an
emotional maturity he would soon bring
to bear on his music
i just want to be less sensitive and
less of a pest he writes in one
what i am feeling has to do with my
insecurities and i have to handle that
on my own
an autographed letter from the rapper
also sold for
17 000 i didn't know what an insecurity
was when i was 16.
yeah you know what a lot of them are now
oh come on come on wait what is this
uh a come remember how you say that word
commemorative
commemorative postage stamp featuring
wu-tang clan it's signed by the group's
rapper producer rca
sold for eight thousand dollars man
maybe i should just start signing stuff
so that one day
i think you're good oh you're still
working on the
dinosaur oh yeah look at my dinosaur my
dinosaur
like so funny liked when i did that
yesterday look at my little t-rex right
here it's only
nine million dollars 188 pieces that i
self-assembled
call me mr akia all right do you have a
good joke there are no good jokes today
you have no good jokes
all right while visiting the museum i
saw my ex-girlfriend standing across the
hall but i was too self-conscious to say
hello
there was just too much history between
us
at the museum do you want to know what
you should uh
no no no let me see let me see let me
just see real quick hurry up before
we're done let me show you
a good joke so this is a live
this is a live search for a good joke
don't tell anybody anything hold on
that was your joke that was a bad joke
now i'm going to say a joke
and when i say the joke everyone's going
to laugh no
hold on no hold on
uh no
how is a girlfriend like a laxative
they both irritate the [ __ ] out of me
[Laughter]
zero funny zero percent funny
if i did the jokes every day you guys
would be here
non-stop tell them what you searched
immature jokes
goodbye good bang bang hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of lunch money as
much as we did and don't forget
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five so go check them out there's a link
in the description that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends